here in the south of england behind
these beach huts is a very weird and
wonderful floating houseboat village
well sometimes it floats and other times
it sits on mud because of the tide but
that doesn't matter right now so without
further ado let's roll the title card
welcome to the houseboat community in
which i reside
my name is hamish mackenzie and i look
on myself as a boat renovator this
community of houseboats is about 50
strong i can safely say there's no two
identical to a large degree they exhibit
the
character of the people who live on them
so let's get to know hamish he has seven
boats he has a microwave as a postbox
he can do this with a saw
he has a grand collection of
let's leave that there
hamish moved here 32 years ago after
falling on tough times
well i found myself homeless and
chatting to a friend about
they sat in the other and we got
chatting about boats
and this place pops into my mind and
three weeks later i was living here i'd
bought my first boat managed to move
here down here for pennies
this is verda this is a boat i live on
that's based on a two train
this is an old ambulance an old coach
and nose code or for jumbo jet where on
earth do you get a nose cone from a
jumbo jet in a
farm yard not far from here i've been
after a nose comb for a while
fair enough i do think it's a
particularly free lifestyle just because
i can
build it and design what i like and have
building rigs i don't have planning
permission
now i know what you're thinking why on
earth is there a bus or a scrap car on a
boat i just want to know what it's going
to look like he said
that's not a fun idea or go for it
tractor wheels make perfect windows
but you're thinking all these ideas are
gelling in your brain i don't really
draw anything like it's all up here
i use secondhand materials because i
think there's life in inanimate objects
they've lived one life and you're just
changing the purpose by becoming a house
boat
reusing stuff and giving it a second
life it's just
generating its own energy and this
was a speed boat the spaces you create
using different shapes that's when they
start becoming fun a lot of it starts
designing itself after a while because
these things fit together quite nicely
and
i could build whatever i could imagine
the only constraint on my building style
was my own ability